the formal name for france today is the
fifth french republic
the fifth which as i'm sure you'll be
aware is more republics than most
nations go through
this factoid raises the obvious question
how
how has france gone through so many
republics so the only way to find this
out is by looking at why the first full
republics failed and what led to the
french continuously implementing new
ones
so the first french republic the one
with all the guillotining aka the fun
one was brought into being in 1792
after the french revolution three years
earlier it was to put it mildly pretty
unstable and it saw several forms of
republican government ending in the
consulate
whereby three men consuls led by the
first council napoleon bonaparte ran the
country as a dictatorship
in 1804 napoleon proclaimed the
establishment of the french empire with
himself as its emperor
that's republic number one dead
napoleon's rule would come to an end in
1815 when all of europe barring poland
united against him
and after he was ousted came the bourbon
restoration which brought back the old
bull bomb royal family with louis the
18th as france's new constitutional
monarch
he ruled for about a decade before
catching a mild case of death and he was
succeeded by charles the tenth
charles wasn't too keen on being a
constitutional monarch and so he tried
to make himself an absolute one
this didn't sit well with the french
people revolution and charles was
replaced by a constitutional monarch
louis philippe
now louis philippe did respect the
limits on his power but he unfortunately
presided over a decline in french living
standards and so
revolution this revolt part of the
broader 1848 revolution saw the creation
of a presidential republic which then
elected a man called louis napoleon as
president
now the french constitution prevented
the president from seeking re-election
which louis napoleon didn't like and so
he did what all capable men would he
overthrew the government in 1851 and
declared the establishment of a second
french empire with himself ruling as
napoleon iii
that's republic number two dead napoleon
reigned until 1870 when he made the
silly mistake of picking a fight with
prussia
prussia won napoleon was captured and
during his captivity members of
parliament declared him deposed in the
institution of another french republic
now the third french republic was a
successful one and despite a deeply
divided electorate it managed to survive
until 1940 when france fell to germany
in the second world war
most of it was occupied in the bits that
remained free from occupation became the
french state led by philippe patom
that's republic number three dead as
you'll know many in france opposed baton
and the three french forces in exile
would end up regaining control of the
country in 1945 when it was liberated by
the allies there was a nationwide
referendum the next year which approved
the creation of a fourth republic
now the fourth republic was a bit
different the french parliament and
prime minister had immense power whereas
the president had very little
the fourth republic also attempted to
bring many of france's colonies into
france itself
most preferred independence and as the
french empire disintegrated it was only
algeria which became a formal part of
france
now the fourth republic was frankly a
hot mess political divisions were
extreme and parliament was in complete
deadlock
and this deadlock caused problems for
the french military since the constant
changes in policy meant that they
couldn't secure algeria and the rest of
the french empire
this upset them and so to stop algeria
from falling away they did the only
thing they could in 1958
they staged a coup this saw parts of the
french military seize control of algeria
and soon afterwards corsica
president renee cotty declared that the
fourth republic had failed and that
civil war was inevitable unless charles
de gaulle returned as president
de gaulle was basically instated as a
dictator for six months with near
unlimited power and during the period he
oversaw the creation of a new
constitution
in september of 1958 de gaulle put this
new constitution to the people in an
empire-wide referendum which was
overwhelmingly backed
the fourth republic was dead long live
the fifth republic
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette the pastry section
danny maloney marvin cassell kelly
moneymaker rob waterhouse john bisquez
mo james castaneda aaron the whites
jordan longley marcus arsna
gustav swan jerry lamdin john bailey
calling castleman rasheed ali spinning
three plates filled
oink oink maggie patzkowski david
silverman izzy
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle spencer lightfoot and winston
caywood